[Music]
welcome all right and we are live matzo
gaming dotnet iron Lord podcast with
shadow report is two fine gentlemen in
the room today sorry I didn't I said we
just find you who are you sir what do
you do sir another angle games a small
independent studio from Warsaw Poland
all in the house was in a lot a good
polish games here
yeah and we represent in the shadow of
the road it's our first project first
ever we are bringing the Baxters to see
how what kind of feedback can we can we
take from you guys and show it okay cool
and what is your role specifically with
the game to be honest and the founder of
the we have royalty here and who is this
fine gentleman I was talking to earlier
dealing with share of the row what your
role the game sir
and your name I'm a 3d artist and a
level designer so if you like what you
see it's me
Christian reserves is my name so down
I'm his partner and a friend awesome
awesome
so let's get it to shout out a role
quickly just a brief synopsis so for
people who don't know the game cuz I
know why I was drawn to the game I saw
XCOM like turn base I saw my name's
Laura cogito star like ninjas in feudal
Japan so I saw that and then I saw
robots so let's break down there so Khan
so have you seen magic
yeah okay let's talk about give us the
whole premise of shadow the role shadow
of the road is the turn-based tactical
game which makes LPGs elements and it
happens in federal Japan which is
currently at the Civil War because the
we are mixing the history actually in
the 19th century us you say went to
Japan trying to conquer it okay in our
history its Great Britain and the
Emperor is fighting with chocolate and
the Emperor is interested in Western so
tired society and machines he's trying
to take over control in Japan but we
have to resist it yes but shaggin
shaggin odd and samurais don't want to
lose their privileges but they lose with
the yes you gonna lose with that they
don't they don't have a chance
and our main character loses a great
battle he loses his master and his
Iranian you know that's our no Roden oh
yeah we talk it out with talking samurai
talk so he's out of control he's trying
to get his honor back his privileges
back and he's really desperate and he is
given a mission to get a mysterious boy
okay who could turn the cause of war
that this mysterious boy I'm assuming
has some key fact or element to help him
charge the change the tide of said war
not to spoil or anything or anything
like that place and very important role
in this conflict here what we're here is
when magic comes in the gates to the
other side of the Japan and he also
plays a big political role this is also
this is Oscar all right I'm so except we
gotta get to the game we gotta get it so
let's get right into it
I'm very hype I'm loving what I'm
hearing so hardest skirmish actually I'm
not sure if I'm gonna win this is our
mic main cars are big all my look at the
detail or the closest Wow
this is the boy for us to manage the boy
right he's his a supporting character he
lives he feels his meditating to support
the other team members and peers his
mother also we need that we need we need
some magic as well in our reign so she
she's she's a witch God so that first
that's why he's a magical boy that's why
the mess because she's a witch was he
has four block polyfill now first of all
the engine looks phenomenal
what engine are you guys using is this
unreal is this you ready all right yeah
this looks fantastic
it's a top-notch HDR P High Definition
render pipeline that we are using it and
we are pretty pretty happy with results
that we are able to make
yes it's about five characters per part
with the support can every everyone in
our team plays a important role in terms
of the story no one is expendable in our
time in our team and the funny part is
that we can possess and take over the
control of the enemies when the correct
skills are used we can take over every
enemy in good from the other side and
use it to to bring some destruction now
the main character let's talk about just
basic gameplay from the main character
the abilities moving around the map is a
completely turn-based like it XCOM give
us give us the basic gameplay and maybe
what would be different from a person
who coming from the XCOM universe we are
showing only the combat system demo
right here but the core game loop
consists of the exploration mode which
is in real time you can explore
different parts of Japan and maybe even
magical side of it
and when it comes to the battle and we
are switching to the ten based combat
there will be some sneaking around and
stealth mode like in for example mutants
your zero and you can approach them
approach have arrived tell us what's
going on right now like robots are
arrived I'm saying ninjas going on are
you taking good what's going on right
now we are fighting with the joint
forces of ninjas allied with the East
Nippon company British conglomerates
which brings high-tech equipment to the
Japan and create the Emperor and in the
civil they're losing now so the idea is
trying to evade they're going into the
vessel because that's what they lay in
the cow traps out they turn okay when
their enemies are wounded their play
style will adjust to the situation so
there will be some wall of fires from
the flamethrower ninja their spikes
under is on the ground
so our job right now when they're in
this kind of defensive mode how do we
what are some good strategies like
chasing chasing situation what's our
main character it's based from based on
a Toshiro Mifune character a real one
which can attack many targets at once in
a sequence so the distance will not play
the influencer was a playing okay well
now what about Lu state we all know the
boy is very critical to the story so do
we have to protect him as a support
character at all times
if he dies does the game turn in like
what's his role in the final release
where this will be the case we have to
protect the boy and the sataro
there are two main characters that
cannot die I think other characters or
we can fall on the battlefields and
toaster oven will break and Grimm bring
them back so our team is as I mentioned
before really important from terms of
the story so we cannot afford
spermatophores
trying to enforce connection in
storyline in our gameplay as well nice
if you track if the story is about
protecting the boy you have to protect
the boy right
so basically it could change like
mission types could change your your
role for is either particular making
making combos might influence the
relationships between each character and
maybe enforce some of the skills that
they can use it with each other
Louis likes teleport like teleports or
supportive skills okay automation that
ways our our game is story-driven the
decisions that player will have to make
will impact the relation between
characters there will form an alliance
or stronger bond between some of them
that will affect how they connect on the
battlefield so
they're an our boy have very specific
skill okay
let's see what the boy could do okay
this might actually packed the game if I
had if I was pre-op for your free offer
we okay it's okay don't worry about it
we go try but the boy does too much we
understand he can connect to the yokai
dimension and bring a yokai instead of
one of our characters Wow Wow
now we're getting advantage of all the
technologies how we come back the
technology now Wow
this is fire
I am feeling this she's kuma a full
month of spider that can possess and
take on to take over the control from
the enemies that I mentioned before arch
now is very very very loving everything
about the art style right now very
impressive here he's doing this thing
still got a couple of enemies left on
the field
he can throw his shuriken gadget now but
to let me ask you could between stages I
know you says very story driven right
okay so between stare is do or they like
cinematics how does the short but you
say you have to pick choices different
kinds of interaction that and the
choices that the player will have to
make lots of cinematics cutscenes but
also dialogues in the meantime of
exploration mode there will be some some
moments that we have to decide what to
do next in terms of real-time gameplay
awesome awesome
and how far we in development now how
far you guys been working on it release
oh we are planning to release in 2020 to
2022 it is at least two more years to
develop and to produce the contents we
will try to fair enough and right now
obviously PC but I mean I would love
this one console I would really love
this okay again I think this genre
turn-based in arts yes one of my
absolute favorites and notoriously it's
always been kind of restricted to PC but
I would again people have shown that
they really gravitate towards it when it
does come so it would be awesome if you
guys could get this the Xbox series X is
coming down the road in 2022 you know
they the place they should find any
ideas that he thoughts about that for
now we are focusing on participation but
we like to take one step at a time
absolu PC first and because all next but
we are considering the PC and the Xbox
version as well as in the switch maybe
did you say Nintendo's DS a Nintendo
switch bother in theory telling us which
will be able to do it but with the Unity
engine is it possible that
yes it is possible unity provides us
tools for compassion and the
multi-platform targeting our pipeline
will need some adjustment it is it is
more than possible so scalability is not
as big as an issue as some may fake when
it comes to a game like this with unity
its notes for us to think well see the
polling got it down your eyes team for
him it's not it's not a thing I'm gonna
switch supporter so I gotta I gotta give
some love to the switch fix your face
bTW you see dude this is awesome
we're really excited gonna follow you
guys journey shadow of the road
definitely on my bucket list or
something I'm very interested you guys
yes it's actually really important for
us at this moment of development because
we estimate our value and okay if we
want to develop exploring more story
like more more cinematics all that helps
so you heard it here first
steam wish let's disguise it helps it
helps the developers helps them get it
out get more things accomplished we want
to see more games like this come to
console and finish on PC absolute
pleasure to have you guys around this is
fantastic
we're gonna be charting your journey
shadow of the road Lord Cognito iron law
podcast Lords of gaming that dagger to
their first
[Music]